[Music]
blood plasma
is saving the lives of people with covet
19
but there isn't enough of it that's why
scientists have been trying to recreate
the antibodies it contains
in the lab and they've done it
they've developed defensive proteins
that can successfully fight off
coronavirus
the us president was even treated with
them
but these antibody drugs aren't in wide
use
even though they could make the
difference between life
and death
all sounds great we still don't have
definitive data
but trials are set to get underway like
so much in this crisis it's
learning by doing and it's thanks to
some brilliant minds from the world of
science
this blood plasma can stop a coronavirus
infection
in its tracks the antibodies of
recovered patients can be used to treat
people with covid19
it's already proven effective for
patients including lute foodacci
at the start i was very sick my wife
sent me here in an ambulance
i spent two days in the normal ward but
then they decided to send me to
intensive care
i was just drained
lutfu's condition became so severe that
he was placed on a ventilator
it was then that dr halber and his team
gave him plasma from a recovered patient
the patient received the plasma after
his respiratory condition and his lung
function deteriorated
significantly within a day or two he'd
stabilized and we were able to take away
the breathing support
to get the plasma you need blood donors
who've already survived covid19
their blood has neutralizing antibodies
that can render the coronavirus
harmless
the plasma is given to the patient
through a transfusion
then the antibodies within it get to
work fighting the virus
before the patient's immune system has
produced enough defensive proteins of
its own
the plasma clearly did the trick for
lutefudachi
but the successes remain isolated cases
and the general effectiveness
is yet to be proven in studies however
doctors say plasma therapy
is helping the most severely ill
patients
many doctors would like to use plasma
more often
ideally giving it to patients in the
early stages of the disease
when it's likely to work best but the
problem is
there isn't enough of it
we've come to realize that everyone who
recovers from coronavirus has a
different amount of antibodies in their
blood
only those with a high level can be
suitable donors
but can the antibodies be produced
without the need for a donor
that's exactly what researchers in
braunschweig are working on
this tube contains an entire gene
library so a collection of genetic
material
in our collection we have 10 billion
different genes that's the entire
repertoire of what our body
has available to produce antibodies
in this gene library the scientists
found an
antibody that works perfectly against
sars cove too
in lab tests it completely prevented the
human cells
from being attacked they were then able
to reproduce the antibody based on its
genetic blueprint
and produced the first dose of their
antibody drug
it has major advantages over the plasma
therapy because it can be manufactured
in large quantities
and at a consistent quality with the
right funding
human trials of the team's drug could
begin as soon as next month
and the scientists work can begin to
save lives
and let's talk to stefan double who
featured in that report
we just saw you holding up a tube to the
camera what was
in there uh actually this very small
vial contains literally the complete
immune reaction of mankind in respect to
antibodies
so more than 100 people from all over
the globe
donated blood and we extracted from that
blood the blueprints
to build antibodies against almost
everything so
more than 10 billion different
blueprints
in form of genetic code for antibodies
against different diseases are in this
while
and my laboratory has now developed a
technology to identify
one specific antibody which binds
to saskaf2 for example or to other
viruses so this antibody
can then neutralize the virus and can be
used
as a drug to fight the disease and it's
a molecule which is made
in our own body so it's not a chemical
or not an artificial substance it's a
molecule which is identical to the one
which is
in our body anyway if we get the
infection
can you briefly briefly let me in on the
secret how did you actually
pinpoint that out of how many did you
say
10 billion how did you do that
it's a trick which i co-invented about
30 years ago
together with some other people and it's
a molecular biology
trick where we managed to connect
the blueprint so the genetic information
to the function which is the proteins in
form of nanoparticles
so we have 10 billion different
nanoparticles which can be then selected
by a simple molecular biology experiment
for the binding itself and when you have
the binding of the protein
it has the genetic information in its
backpack
and we can get it back and isolate your
own and get the antibody
so you've managed to produce antibodies
otherwise only found in the blood plasma
of covert survivors
are they just as good though
um well that has to be of course uh
has to be shown in the clinical studies
but uh in principle
our antibody is derived from the blood
of patients and performed
in the blood uh sorry and performed in
the experiments we did
in the pre-clinical studies uh very very
effective and in
it neutralized the antibody in the lungs
and it 100 protected cell culture
against infection so it's very efficient
in respect of protecting against
saskatchewan
what about these clinical studies of
antibody therapies that show
severe side effects like the
overreaction of the immune system how
can you prevent that
this is a very important point and we
thought of that
since the beginning of the design of our
body of our antibody
and we managed actually to
address this problem by changing the
signaling part of the antibody
a little bit by molecular biological
means
so that we completely avoid the
simulation of this
overreaction so in the clinic we expect
not to see any of these overreactions
which are seen in the other antibodies
and and just tell me briefly do antibody
treatments provide
long-term protection against the virus
they provide immediate protection which
is different from
the back side but then they only last
for about one to three months and have
to be
repeated but they can be given
repeatedly
stefan thank you very much interesting
stuff and congratulations on your work
let's take a look at some of the other
corona related stories making news
preliminary results from a study show
recovering from covert protects against
infection for at least five months
public health england attracts 20 000
health care workers and found a previous
infection provided
83 percent immunity similar to a vaccine
the world health organization is looking
at introducing covert 19
vaccination passports for travellers
some countries are already trialling
them
critics call the passports
discriminatory
and wh so scientists are now in the
chinese city of wuhan to investigate
the origins of the pandemic the long
delayed trip follows months of
diplomatic
wrangling beijing argues the virus may
not have originated in the southwest as
scientists suspect
over now to our science correspondent
derek williams if you've got a question
here's the email
feedback feedback.englishdw.com
type expert in the subject line or leave
a comment on our youtube channel
if you get a first vaccine shot made by
one developer
what happens if your second shot is from
a different developer
as the pandemic reaches a really
critical stage in many countries
in one of them britain health
authorities have changed some rules
on how they're going to vaccinate one of
them was this
that for the second shot in a two-shot
regime
in some rare and exceptional
circumstances
for example if the individual concerned
is thought to be at immediate
high risk vaccinators will be allowed
to mix and match vaccines if they don't
have any more of the product
from the first shot so just to clarify
there are three candidates currently
approved for use in the uk
from pfizer biontec from moderna
and from astrazeneca and they all
require two shots
of the same vaccine to work as well as
trials demonstrated
this decision means that if someone
there gets the first shot
say of the moderna vaccine when they
come back for the second one
they could theoretically receive one
made for example
by astrazeneca if the authorities
have run out of the moderna vaccine the
thing is
nobody yet knows exactly what kind of
impact that could have
because there have been no mix and match
trials
each manufacturer carried out their own
trials
involving only two doses of their own
product
so the question of how interchangeable
they are
is really wide open one american
professor told the new york times that
in
his view the british authorities in the
current emergency
were trying to guess their way out of a
mess
the british guidelines however call the
move reasonable
since in different ways all three
vaccines target the same
area on the virus what's called the
spike protein
and experts in the uk think a second
dose of any other approved vaccine
would be better than no second dose at
all to be honest
i don't know enough about vaccine
science to make any confident
predictions and opinions among those who
do know enough
are divided but i can say i think
basing decisions like this on reasonable
assumptions
rather than on hard data is risky
and a lot of experts agree
you